Good evening, excuse me for a little delay
people are praying for the technicians to
who accompanied developer barbosa a
time ago the structure a little
different
to substitute an Argentine for the miner
the exchange started well
where are people have watched
Live
is however in galt today after editing
video is also recording
available on channel 2 of sailing through the
extension can watch by page
ibge will also link to
over there
well this is an event that is was inspired
in the event that is done in the United States
event is actually a personal program
Do what you do is the tomato and they
analyze the applications we have
some applications that brazil when the
collective goes to the attack
He has done a review plate. I have not seen it.
no one to publish anything like politics
provided that it is not Finnish
against the terms of use of the
playstation
You can play, if you want, right?
It is clear that it has good applications
bad the good the bad has the
love in every way but we
has a currency of exchange, we can
speak as soon as part of the future ne
the application can be feature must
go through a few attempts to
According to some online games, you have to
have some kind of review we do
Review in Brazil, we can not
of many people and a way that he
found to do this for more
people
is to pick up some applications and do this
review captive challenge playing some
points that will serve the
developers
It's not today's pink today.
in partnership with ctg são paulo
Is anyone there?
São Paulo is suffering by helping to film
what a hugo cheer is and we make editing that
consecutive that you submit to that
page there between the applications there
usually how the
google team we even choose
the applications and do the review there
featuring is also powered marine
android developer advocate is based
here in Sao Paulo
you may have seen some maybe more
I hope you have seen one of the videos
something I produce that are the videos
technical and android
I think some news may come
for me there
but as it is a very cocoa plan were the
three applications that we have selected
the first one was the brandsclub né
that the part with the pension of the own
tok shop then accompanies the largest club
from Brazil wherever you are and
pay attention to the renowned brands with
90% of the survey compares the high
in 4.2
everyone has recently
have on the internet watching later
See you want to get the qr code for
lead straight to the store
another who has already chosen the sounds does not
certain names once same with you or
custom music you
may want country with your style o
corinthians buy a ranking with the
most heard on each artist's albums
said digital media assessment 4.8
it is also the educational qr code of today is the
the team died because I lost what
Can you manage finances?
personal finance of the company's day
web in a simple intelligent way
protected with high security and
reliability
language technology rating 4.9 good
beans that the three applications are
very well rated however with notes
above 4,541 already has a requirement that
to be prominent in place torque
is the minimum will have evaluation above 4
It's a must have at least 11 people
that reviewed application does not have to have
note
at least above 4 and there is the whole
guy issue from there and we will
discuss a little bit of each application
good first people do not start with
brandsclub staff to invite
someone who has been writing here
for me here please, everybody then there
already known by the wife of
sail for vans
go ahead and that's July in the face of
with those adriana is one thing
stay comfortable, the sound is coming and going
It's good to talk a little bit about the
application of patients than the
application that works the most it's a
club club is actually
an e-commerce based flash and
mails then we have campaigns
campaigns last a while
Mother Ana says 5 to 6 days and the user
you can go in there and navigate within
shopping campaigns
this is basically what it was thought of
first for web after was employee
had an android that exactly it already
there was a good time to travel a few years
that's where we invested in the application
It's the following I'll stay here, I'll do it.
a documentary we can combat a
Talk about the app then July
come on the code you can practice
same cup only then just to remind myself
I'll make some comments that maybe
we can continue I will not repeat the
same things
And today is the idea today was more
to focus on which standards of
android development and also in
navigation that when we noticed
many applications but they have
sin a little bit this part of
navigation
It's good the first thing we do.
Seeing there looks that focuses on the application
to have an express looking screen
and it does not only have to come out of the
accident is that the client software is
call the ex's staff and went riding
who knows how to do it live is who does not know
does this in fact is Flemish color in the
use of it is sure have to wear the veil
phenomenon but the drama that is living
here my orders navigation area
My account is that 80 of the problems
the campaigns in my orders are areas of the
application you can not at least
name of another hidden
if I do not go on the menu I do not know what it requires
your part of my requests, right?
in this part that we recommend using
would be an example navigation dollar is that
she is the same as him - including the
left to right and that's more
intuitive
the staff use or you can use this
the same theme, the pilot has to
example may confuse the electrons you
click down the list of circles by
example tripoli campaigns my requests
My account would be nice
ok, good shopping cart
the shopping cart and obviously I
I will not choose the people of the clear
What do you guys have a shopping cart?
because the shopping cart is almost
100% mobile commerce applications
the guys put net with bruno put and
That's when you ask me, man.
purchase is an important item of your
its obvious functionality is that it
now you will finalize the purchase but one
shopping cart is the understand me action
they say it's not an indication if I call there
upon
neighborhood action I do not have an item
action that is there does not have a thing
wrong there you are the more the car is
important because you have to see how many
items there are cool you can use then
there in the bishan drug an area my cart
the same way but there is no action
you may have to action for example would be
cool up to an action if I do
to finish the check out there
would be an item
but it's something that also leaves me
I put it in my cart and show it
this message is not
in fact we recommend that you guys
have no one to use in the modal area
because this causes user frustration and
besides being a visiting club that finishes
by locking the user interface
better shape or leave blank screen even
technician entered such an empty screen or when
the cart icon has nothing
disables it puts in a color
different to inform the user not to
You come here because you are.
enabled but avoid this type of
dallas situation but it's not just for
cart not for any kind of down
try is good without trying to avoid because
what hangs a few users
it was a bit complicated
this is a case a little more
it's a different one because we have
a matter of the car is shared
from a and b and the products they have stock
this online stock
So we end up having to do the
call and this is the service message
not cool
The idea is cool and if you can do it in
if he considers it but does not show it
for example put mother puts interface
and placed a message on the screen
same car under your control is empty
keep shopping but not
block and will i am so you show the
and the screen has 11 brands and also
plus an empty cart anyway
car was empty total gets cooler
from what looks like a modal
besides that you are using a cellphone in this
case but on the tablet to be more
comfortable and also the entire map of
navigation bell because of a warning
decision by a notice on the screen itself will
stay cool too
well this part here is a message that
I took from their application but that
people find this
in 90% of today's educational
developed with assets of high
personal quality because I put this
reason the slide there like that android that
including gains in critical lines
android because this looking screen
so you getting a goose feather
on top is but if you look just like this you
can distinguish if an android ep is not
an android ep are not otherwise looks like an ep
android it no longer fall into the category
after giving a highlight with the captive
since I do not know mainly
with the elements here you can get the
google play app is from google
plus on youtube we have the options of
menu navigation drug for example but
Do not have this little set of
there is more like the user knows that will have
that clicking good if a list of actions to
my account
obviously I'm going to click on this list
I'm not going to give an instruction
a little set 19 click here
I looked that I know what they want in my
on the streets I know I'm going to apply
my machines one more indication
for that
another thing is the button to exit the account
This is an action should be where I
I have quite the neighborhood action button
only because it is a pattern that facilitates
very user and I got you
started implementation and gave a
stop then I'm on the way
using that will not at least 30 only
you're not using it, just need to hit the
part of d
this screen here is to place an icon in the
left with the same tire I called
Ground is already nice here on my account.
It would be wrong, I know I'm going to
side of the icon globe is
it's already on the right track what I hit
on the action barnabe key
that up, something else, you too
here, too, neither am I - the
android they are very similar to
android platform they are not the
platform
I can not customize can customize
but something that is closer
gives u
so I stay close to what the
platform or if you really innovate
a certain control
because it has found a new environment is not
against innovation or come on man either
Something is going wrong with that.
This is a logout because someone has
the notion why I put this slide
with the little boy there is no kick
This is how it comes out, but I
I have information, I have to inform
What I'm going to pay out erases because this is
expected in a new captive that I have
credit card information or I can
I really hope you're cool.
You do not save anything so it's a
expected behavior
This is what we recommend only.
they were very educated if very
specific you will logout
this may imply that you have to
pay 100 reais to me if it was any
Such a mountain thing has a fine
because the affirmation is legal to know your
account we will pay for all
credit card security
excellent I already hoped that you
do this when I leave
application but the message to that
If I still want to leave, I still want to leave.
that old personal story in the face of
mask that did not want any
easier to be unwilling
really wanted to quit the app is
64 more to exit the application
true, right?
so he left he left but he paid
card where not after the pgm-fi guy
could new card and know that you do not
save his card of what to do
because as it is known the card
we who see this information then left
erased it was just remembering that he
make a good wish july some
Quiet and peaceful quiet commentary
I just wanted to share the whole
staff in charge goes there
playing at the rate will also pass the team
from samuel in karachi
I left so joy adrenaline is a
thing is not a disease but represents a
personal blow is with those who accompany the
responsible for lex
the brandsclub we are aware of
some changes
We have to do what we think.
we tried to change you see a service
google down there just for being
a lot about it is and ends up that part
and we end up leaving a
bit back and such but you know it is
very important but our pilot there already
also it will be this change also
by entities the key of the city for
example
I think this is a great company.
which is well known and yet
attended an event here at the
application evaluation live you
value can only participate with the
community of the genre is how you
they think that the really cool guy is the
The fee also came to help the
hexa to defend itself but we try
always very close also with the part
of development
We know it's no good just to
creation and send the images to
galera do has accompanied the tv has
that read the messages have to see everything
This has to have more how it works.
even from thing codes to
make everyone's life easier is not
very good approach that you like
a lot of people try to participate in everyone
events here, and when people
can see the videos of the most ever
accompanying and have to take advantage of
enjoy even who knows it is difficult
rely on this help has a material
internet has all that but there are some
things that are getting higher have debts
that we take all doubts about
to the stage with staff in favor
good if a little on the microphone side because
like this
good, the idea is to realize the
application from now on I will
talk a little more and get another
aspect our next the next
invited here but what I wanted
show enough discipline through
mainly the part of
adherence to navigation and adhesion edson
Pub
We want everyone to use the
action goes again everyone a great
goes to the applications in general is a
good practice the site a bar because the two
one reason why the current one is
using android there then theoretically
We like training him for you guys.
guy picks up the app he already saw max one
bar there he already knows he has to be
there an icon frame he knows that if he
to get him back to navigation he is already
used to it
it is additionally facilitates modifications
have support there and now you can
use it save code is and a
second reason is the lens passionately
and facilitated and the second reason for
It's a wiki, but it's sharper.
integrates easy it saves for example
pixels on your screen with you
and that they had left the app you
take a botton I have to
Promises 4048 pixels 50 pixels
height and remove this place there in a healthy
another 50 pixels on my screen to
put more local content but I do not know
put some because it's a better promotion
like this
besides we try to do everything
interface that will help you
designers designers is curious
there is also more space in the cast of the movie
chico xavier a long time ago people
I quarreled that I had only 128 by 128
pixels
today these 960 screens have a
Wonderful, man, but then finally
idea a little bit of it now in the
personal sounds can come here can come
for thoughts only
Let's show another aspect a
Let's talk a little bit about the
application for people presents band plays
and it's not my name is fernando is the sound is
a social music network where
people wanted instead of a profile
They create a kind of radio and it's
subscribe songs playlists music
share things about music
this app the android version this
social network only more summarized without
part of the social network even in it you go
stay on the cadastrá playlists is register
their songs and listen to them online more
in front of us we think about putting
part of listening offline as well
synchronization but for now the on
cool line
well I got the app I liked
some things we will use
navigation drug started some
elements we are going to take a look at
There are people who can eat a little.
Good, I liked it
the login screen church had connecting
with google plus is for me only had one
little more up releases tomorrow start
to give a slightly greater emphasis but
legal point multiple positive accounts
do not know that only she prefers to use that
she suddenly has 14% social
trust another and take advantage of the
talk about it because it made me some
search launch google plus and
overwhelming majority always faithful place
while google than the service but
there is only one small difference
beauty
if I have you I want
already existing I can have a little in
doubt which is so but if you do not have
a user I can use the networks
even though I already logged into the
with and a half before I can now a network
Social
and then maybe this last part here
instead of entering and registering
you can create an example service
place with your account sounds for example and
do not split into two actions like enter
existing account register
why you can do for every
click there to display a second screen
where then his mail and if not
had returned 404 entered 3 1 200 in
200 that would codes and save folder
but believe in the mail and password
and so I thought it looked beautiful
screens have a
It's cool from the blue and the title.
right
then a first of them in is the one of the
I do not need to touch the boat.
your login yet but I would trade
this part with a little confusing you
have an account the post of new place as
I eat google plus for example
are just one is much more than they are
now here's one more tip than in the
time to conquer talk now to laine
until it's really cool there, okay?
well here I thought I put it
here is what I missed
you have a big screen and it was done
no nexus four aces that shock
this is a reasonable screen and still
little of that crow né to another player this
he stayed under the play bar
maybe you can do a test for
you avoid those first screen or
so we can leave it a little clearer
which depends on a smaller screen that has
more content and some why it ends
covering the last playlist
the last part the user may not know
that had content down then it is
cool the others are playing heard
pg
the guy knows he can go to the side
for the key the pgp is excellent
We are now seeing here in a bar.
There you are, I selected the top right now.
It looks cool and I'm going to give it
a very interesting and uniform look
already looking like an android app if
look here you already know that the application
android, do not doubt the web
html5 apps is on android we know
which is in fact android but there by the part
and what's cool you can with
good platform thing you can integrate
search with your app as your
own phone with the probable everything
more but you click on the search that is
happening tonight show bar cool
It's a ball show, I'm going to find one.
test what it is a new screen
which one would be ideal now you use this
same as you did only one main screen
Let's start a new one that had to
doing so makes it likely to search the
own main screen
because there you avoid stacking
understood
That was one of the things I would give to you guys.
see a new transition screen have been
tablet after she can play the
more title ok
another thing in relation to navigation
I never said that the service started well.
to plumb
but there it is a pity to see gay chan
But there's a strange thing I'm in
first screen and appeared an up navigated
calls you back to where you
because how I got even revenge
navigate personnel when that
Minor signal therein
who is taking the user to the screen
and hierarchically prior to that which
you are
do not confuse this with coming back many
Sometimes he has it, he comes back to
screen but for now that is not
a back because we are going to an example of the
our brandsclub framework send a
email with a certain promotion was that the
clickon and half it opens right on the page
showing me if I press
come back this time where I go
back in the middle because I'm going to
to the way your squeeze it piaí
cool and brings me the list of campaigns by
example is that I just finished an application
of you and where you're just taking
a game on
so look at the drug since it tends to
wrong on that damn screen
in fact the use of the icon is wrong
including a little video that we did
about alexandra neno in the debate
when you have the icon for april drug
and eighty-three stripes actually the op
What could we do because the night is
when you have a screen to go back
so in that initial screen you did
almost all right
Let me, I should have wanted those
three, and then you know you can open the
menu and also that you managed to
activate from what I understand you want
come back
he wants to go back to the login screen there
when I wanted at least there is a menu
so your guy the goal is a
bit wrong at that point more time
For me, this land, too.
Maybe I already mentioned the brandsclub
had also spoken in the personal settlers
forget the little personal
poetinha list android sold only one
Little finger he is not cause set list
android do not use
This is 11 platforms here.
I understand market share but anyway
so let's get it right so let's go
I put there bidders analyst of davy 9 leaving
I already know that you opened click and do
some white action but no navigation
has used to be in doubt that I do
here he does not know what to click there
And opening the bon rock was a little something I
I think I'm on the way, it's okay.
application is observation I did not put the
law be aware of the size of the cycle
play under the player
You have to remember that you have to talk -
a size of 50-50 pixels per 50 kits
on the buttons people do not have to have a
carrot then the guy aim the button there
so make an icon that is a bit
more confortable
Yes, but you want to comment?
some note was dinner ourselves
only that
thank you, thanks, the bridge staff opened
a good audience question with sunshine
we have not been there for a long time so
We lost a big club that I
I got it already that I had a great mark
I enjoyed the sun and showed more screens
doing some things were still going on here
I did not comment because I did not compete in
same things
We've already seen a little action
neighborhood new life ii leaving hertha is
is a very interesting resource that you
also know space on the same screen
way
so now without going too personal
gift that will come here we will do well
staff can also pick up a
bit to the people of the application
where the idea came
I found it very interesting concept is that
You go to the web first a little bit.
for us it reads in a control scheme
double entry financial
we did all the engineering in the system
the account becomes easy for the user
input to information input
recording expenses and revenues was
it is a very complex engineering by
behind the ept demand we got it
arrive at the registration fee
I wish a field could only enter us
did this because of the digital keyboard
value and easier
and then we can see a lot of
information and can discover the
accounts for him to take the heavy lifting
in the guy's hand, right?
for that we took a step further
which is the step taken he discovered afterwards
go on the web with fig confirms the
launch
so this is a platform that has a
bargain made with 80 points
we made a rap five script guards
also can not only integrate
It's cool what I selected educational is that
I found it simple because that's how I feel.
a problem is a problem with an always
tries to launch the expenses any
indicative and always said this is because
I start well after I forget and I
so it's very complicated to enter
I like some points they had to
idea of ​​being very simple but maybe the
over simplicity sacrifices some
points and you can not escape
a glance you stop here is good
The first screen I found very interesting is
the first time it shows up a stone
only the first time, that's not good at all
a detail that she is really very
simple
maybe it's cool to put a chance with
She's going to say cool with the action.
icon there with the educational name does not have
problems when you made the complaint
its implementation
only this idea of ​​using the icon
on top of it we can
every day in a way that this role in
layout that she uses a library of ours
use a sherlock, there's no problem
but here it is cool for example that and if
start talking google something else
click the icon does nothing on the link né
if you lose some of the power of information
of taking the site also depends on
wipe the clip already the site already
interesting to have a direct action there
What worries you is that you do not have a
use in-app privacy
so for example
at the time very good but use can
ask these guys I'm going too and
mail to them I'll talk when I spend
and I do not know that they do this
information I do not know what they do
if they will save these servers will go
To use this to make offer
service that has six United States already
heard and should have a lot going
diverting them from their expenses and
approved to spend less on this.
was eating too much out I do not know what now
Just think of food, that's what I think.
with me and then you do it and I do not know
so the application goal idea is legal but
Who are these guys going to do with the
information that we have a lot of
The concern with this is so
google plus you sign in
show there the executive will do it
Can you do it like this?
I got you to put a term of use
I see topical term
I think it's more transparent for
user so give me a little fear that
have a table start but who are these
guys from the store that came with them
they want information right?
but beauty is cool and there's a lot
simple, maybe it's working a
little more than working as a lecturer
next a bar of humanity a little on the
river ae
On this screen, it's okay.
When I thought it cool, you did well.
direct used kate usa's own
Android and there did not need to fill a
Fantastic form maybe change this
here because this type of access it goes
have to be published soon it will
google plus is being changed
so I'd have the clos
it will already show that screen the
and if this application wants to have access
of the most is a screen partners will create a
step over
Only who is going to say if this account goes there?
be that google plus screen
the sound personnel also the athletes can
look at their captive make with bingo
plus in this pattern but who has seen
That's when I wanted to take a look.
vanunu developer.apple.com yesterday is fine
easy to do the same with android but yes
I already liked it, it's easier already.
type my email and a password
Yeah, but I'm not going to show it to you.
anyone who does not know the application shows a
bit of flow is very interesting
between the value né
and it was a description I came to
work with enrollment scheme already
you receive it
actually when you do not have a die
released on dvd players are then the people
makes a place consultant with your chin
you have in the region and set the tags
you type for what it looks like
restaurant large companies oranges
this way but it's cool so this is cool
already facilitates a little expensive digital what
I felt the way I did not speak a little bit
she gave the power even though I saw
applications and wanted to keep it that way
suddenly allow with the most
a subcategory or something like that
Okay, something that I found kind of
It's strange that I launch it.
my part behind what I threw
but keep open maybe elliott and
Finished Release - Collected
autocomplete because I want to see if
gets released the right amount do not know
that I cashed no amount that I released
there so innocent and that the focus was
But I also know if the father you
come back to how the budget he
will collect that I do not know if it launched
certain and released the value would be taken until
I just talked to him and he just
right order then it got a little simple
too much
This show, what I said here is just for
who does not know the process doing here
it's the web interface
I thought it was cool because I got in there.
got the user in the same way and already
showed that I had released this I thought
week cure using home apps is
a financial study and has no report
do not have anything, there's nothing in here
that I do here I understood I'm not going to
site or girlfriend is missing a
little more than perhaps explained the
first expense first moves
law at the time with the most
translucent and puts it so you can
visit such site and verify your account
in the first century after leaving a
little more forwarded then this is a
thing that we are looking for
legal suggestion that you are seeking a
way to speak the user because people
placed
the very simple android for several reasons
a link to stay agile same thing
boring to do with wherever
fast and the other thing is the issue of
safety
batman has only 20 releases on android
and only the release does not have a balance
There's nothing like that.
any problem
I lost my cell phone, I see nobody's going
see what is good to see this point another
thing that might make you think maybe
because the future there you have this version
for web because not so explicitly
have signed up an ep that I can use
all on tablet
because then you have a tablet of 7
inches because I hope you guys
tablet look like a phone with a
Israel pay I paid for seven
inches and 10 inches and I see it
a phone or a zoom then maybe
It would be nice for you to think about the future.
more elaborate application by tablet
do
It's just that we're all tips is
enjoying the staff just to remember
who does continue tablet that goes
happen in a while, it's already
talking in practice this can
were tuned in our quest for
applications you have board support that
will appear better in the search ranking
applications.
But this flower of safety, I'm not in
It's true, I found how we
after I posted expense I can not
edit once the expense I have
that go there on the web to do this
work there we will do
removals will make it the only thing but
the rest is not sauna, not because in the
truth the system is the same on the web you
has edition removal
but underneath for you never never said
nor remove always makes a throw
contrary according to him and then to do
this on android
We thought we were going to do it but it's not
one type I the idea of ​​android was to be one
business and took the legal course for
example how do I play cool of
account
as a matter of fact
the neighborhood and that your new
there is no longer the menu and we were afraid
in the previous notification
so there and do you can change your account
some settings to move chan
all this is good for you a bar
reinforcing that I was longing for the
another and put it is that for example this
busy time is what a smartphone there
The person who picks us up keeps the last ones.
20 and only the phone but still the
Come in and see my
last 20 releases understood
maybe they can put it if the guy wants
not only as mandatory but a pin of 4
numbers that can enter the
presenter mouse said a pint four
and it enters the application because
I think as being so beautiful
but so the guy picks up and sees maura end of the
Morning was a dry day already celebrating in this
old who spent they do not do
Do this several times and put something
soccer city every time we go
to use a control application
that there is a padlock there
like in fear in the restaurant, I go
make a launch only assaulted have
that dictating another lady is there
people got kind of cool is the good feedback
sometimes they can also create then do the
launch saw India
I can have an Indian on the home screen.
then I'll make a quick launch with
I click he opened it and where it will open
another tivit in modal format there in the
case above a video there you to the
launch there it gives ok it closes time and
already launches launching evidence
it works there
essence is an application there you
including by some
functionalities
so I do not even need an app
in a restaurant that comes the bill had
the pocket phone puts it there and do it
the launch is back and ready
And there you think it would be worth it.
put a four-day pin of a
thing for never so exposed
understood and then you are a brush you can
one with an infinite cycle are the
latest videos
she demonstrated a more power he can
Climbing on Sunday safely
do but put more information
Suddenly I think so my opinion
The user I have with you expense
financial and everyone has their eyes
You, but what made me a little afraid.
this part has not transposed yes
maybe we'll work a little on the
part of legal security and I work
a bit more the interface but it
cool idea of ​​camera microphone
I tested both ideas of doing the
and I thought it was cool, but I think
that I'm on the way but also that the
It's a good point to be so simple.
also may not be ideal but it is
cool, I have the idea of ​​your advice
do not have much in your own
web
and then I can also use it as well
a responsive web does not cause a span of
something so cool.
Good, but I do not want to comment on something.
I did not want to thank legal feedback.
legal evaluation of the very
Cool it is very good for us
starting out now or else it's good and the
people are going to work a lot and also just
this was our first edition of the
when are sao paulo
we want to do some more
edit maybe not live maybe a few
studio seconds and I want to
still have this format to do
a call for action
where people can
submit applications is someone who
application tackman that was not
selected not only will I know
It's cool, the people.
here participate
We can take advantage of you.
watching online can not participate
pizza with us here I wanted
take the question if someone wants to
ask a question the audience has
first you can talk
It is not true that this
the personal title to the internet
you can move and give a tip is a
old problem of maybe giving a warning
and I'm not today, right?
I think I really like this.
approach because you end up bothering
very user now notification
previously notified something
when you start asking a lot for
user I already said be in app
who is issuing a notification to
me maybe and may have been configured
remind me of a release reminder
of expenses for example but not some
thing of the application and remembering
Good time, I'll tell you, this is everything.
be careful about modification because if you
not just being in the wrong way can
be out some online games by
example notification for advertising has
that take pitzi luzzi wuta then by
example I want to inform you that you have
you want to receive the
notice or notification
yes if this application did not have a
specific objective for this you can
you may actually not be who you are
here and that's not going to be removed by
school but it can be a highlight in the
I thought it was cool but still
otherwise configurable for example
nor does it notify twice a day
lay down my expenses
maybe it might be an idea but I think
maybe start to get away from the focus a little
application but I think it's legal to
idea is also cool but some people
a question is not good at all
is a little bit already gave a little
start by action please only by
1 40 dollars when you
agent or robock to fill your
intention to control both independence
And the people had us today.
I was implementing it and why
you came across it because bill
downe shot of him to support one that
have to understand that tite to launch the
people made with your note
I just wanted to know if this is a good one.
practice 1 to 1 a control version and
706 mouth is cool a question is the
studio citation for the zone and clips is
who could not avoid the studio
maybe wearing a dow cap looks like
to set up the humble
library and he will make you in this life
there is the big question of independence is
one way of 12 is two-handed law
because it was developing in the case
of independence but it ends up generating
a little over head a in the case of
dependence so that's how I said it
enough test to see if it is
impact, but I think you do not
will impact a lot that the land is not
so complex with this very theme
complex and begins to irritate a lot
may be to give a little loss of
performance
This is good practice, but I think
Maybe if you're doing a
look at the studio creed that goes
only you can create the
bild settings he's already looking for
new version lay there do compilation
right of gas also serves to
other languages ​​such as volleyball for example
after speaking that it is a line of the
own google also supports but maybe
one way is to use the cap that facilitates
a little at that point there answered more
now they are here I can confirm
while the pizza reaches eight
It's just to talk about the robot.
recently used another
library that holds what he
does this injection in population time
So take this, this is an extra's.
even the staff of the bass sound and locke
including cool not only my good tip
Take a look at our conversation.
I confirmed that it is legal that Albanian
downloads that she does a while
Create alert
This is what I do not like much
of her time but if she does what
it does at compile time I think
No problem, it's one more question.
not quiet person
well that's it then they showed up for
there google.com more beto marin
we also have the personal community that
android development is Brazil
inside your android faces
developers, it's good, it's the
comunidad code google also like the
created a short time ago
you followed and who is online
Thank you for watching
I'll ask you later, I'll pass on the event.
google plus i'll answer there guys
Thank you so much until the next
it was okay